[Musica]
basta basta è stato bello bella tutti
ragazzi e benvenuti augusto non video
sono fa vj oggi non siamo negli anni 90
ma siamo su super puc
siamo ragazzi su subaru che sarebbe il
play tutorial lo dici a tua sorella che
non sa che cosa sia un computer io se
permetti facciamo level cell e non so se
vi ricordate ragazzi super hot ma credo
di sì perché aveva fatto un sacco di
successo quando lavo porca eva quanti
livelli ci sono e hanno fatto su peruch
che sarebbe sì però dovete stare calmi
calmi
remember one day
puoi scrivere tutto in una sola
schermata che almeno no
remember good day to rimasta chiusa una
canzone di abc basta no mercy no mercy
nessuna pietà nessuna pietà
nessuna però i viking però veloce
eleonora che va beh allora prima in the
super 8
era un gioco dove bisogna
ammazzare la gente
macché ma chi forse dovevo seguire il
tutorial sapete porca eva lanciato
fucile cosa sta succedendo e super hook
differenze super8 cia anche i cosi per i
rampini ok
l'ho colpito perché la gente quando
muore deve essere sparata come superman
nel soffitto
[Musica]
prende le orche va sono morto sono
deficitari con i preti non perforano
fanno saltare solo la persona o no è
innanzitutto andiamo qua primo seconda
cosa ha quindi penso che la per misurare
le superfici bianche che va bene tutti
razzisti con gli sto gioco 2 ora cava
che è impossibile no ragazzi progetto
veramente un casino ok preso ammazzati
anche da morto ma ragazzi l'ultima volta
che ci provo perché l'hanno fatto
esageratamente difficile ma dopo troppo
chiaramente impossibile
ok no no niente regali impossibile anche
con giuro e livello felice che abbia mai
fatto
ed è il primo basta facciamo level cell
e cambiamo sul secondo direttamente
impossibile o fino al me mica vetro mi
fa male bonino mi ci fosse aggrapparmi
al vetro figo porca vacca a calci piero
calci la pistola da porca eva come
faccio
no perché pensione attenzione attenzione
attenzione un cazzo perché non sono
capaci raga in possesso gioco è assurdo
allora 13 di rabbia o che non si possono
prendere pistole di loch ness oro e mia
quella mela presti grazie possibile
merda buona 2 e la terza lancio blu
lancia pistoia ed amato 1 ok non so se
funziona e ci provo ma qualcosa mi dice
che non è vero non è possibile veramente
o fitto così non ci voglio credere
fermi tutti ho fatto la cosa epica 12
datemi un arma qualsiasi quella no ecco
perfetto facciamo buono è difficilissimo
miche macello veramente super hot in
confronto al gioco per bambini
ok sono due il terzo non lo prendono mai
prova invece proviamo ottimo ottimo
movimento
non posso prendere qualche perfetto
premi apprendi apprendiamo da matrix o
accompagnare solo dovresti spostarti da
qua sono tap in al culo aspetto qualcuno
chiarita regalo zio da regalo però mi
dovresti dare la tua appena via per
l'amori potresti grazie gentilmente
grazie 2 merda non l'avevo visto regala
beppe non qua possibilmente via grazie
trova non lo so se lo becco e rega ci
provo mi piace [ __ ] ayane e non ci
arrivo [ __ ] è niente porca eva
quant'è difficile sto livello rosso
andare tipo da qualche parte lassù ci
possa solo per il soffitto in qualche
modo
olè cosa ho fatto dove sono fermi c'è un
arma ii tra l'altro grazie
prendi premiarla a questa l'arma che
avevo prima perfetto allora facciamo in
contrario proprio perché da sopra
vediamo se riesco no porca vacca
perfetto da mio fucile tutta proprio la
faccio sono troppi no ragazzi afferma
beh basta mi sono rotto i c andiamo al
prossimo posso farci warehouse uno che è
fin qua ma solo da cambio mi possa
aggrappare grazie porca vacca salve mimì
da per caso delle armi grazie quello di
matrix devi proiettili lui non devi ai
proiettili lui devia le armi proprio
come possibile ma come faceva però prova
a prenderlo a calci
non lo so e creazione che azioni
incredibile mi serve un arma mi sapeva
ma quella va bene perfetto orca vacca
ok calmi tutti potrebbe essere una cosa
incredibile
questa tela lancio vediamo come va porca
eva
dai devi muoverti da qui per oggi o di
ok perfetto
oddio oddio cosa sto facendo le cose
[ __ ] perfetto vai zio vai zio ma zio
pam vuol dire mancano ma dovrebbero
essere morti tutti in teoria no perché
c'è ancora quello sono storto raga non
ci voglio credere
chi è ma chi manca cosa c'è ancora a ci
sente ancora la sua porca euro
no no non è possibile non ce la farò mai
più rega deve morire
il cugino come ha fatto a morire anno
c'era uno di sotto che sparava ma
[ __ ] l'ha visto ma dove poté posso
sparare anche da morto
iolo scorso cadendo da temi in arma
datemi norma che lo ammazzo mentre
cadeau lo ammazzo mentre cardo datemi la
pistola
datemi una pista asciutta a ya basta
sono morto idiota non infierire
come ho vinto lo stesso cosa da morto
sono vinto da morto no fermi dai mai
arrendersi raga neanche da morti ho
vinto lo stesso non ci posso credere è
ma con la spara che non ha ancora girato
già spara non ha neanche girato l'angolo
come è possibile
come spiega mi fermi tutti fermi tutti a
prova di fare l'epicità fermi tutti
sblocca di ok matrix time
è uno ne muovetevi uscire prezzi di
merda non mi piacciono i tuoi piedi fai
schifo
1 poiché il bordello est a mamma posso
fare 2 3 4 5 6 sia il prima e di più
tutti stu cazzo
7 e vabbè quando è uscito 8 tanta gente
morti tutti o gas che sono morti tutti
ok
continua non ho preso neanche mezzo
grazie
non so neanche se arriva a segno il
colpo come faccio a sparargli ancora
quanto ci metta arrivare a segno e beh
ci stava praga non l'ho preso
formica quanta gente sta 18 si times 70
ho visto nella possibile ho vinto vito
this is spartano it this is it
michael jackson this is my pazienza che
va a farsi [ __ ] n'è valsa la pena
però dipende se subito fa milioni di
views si tu chi lei lei chi di
abbandonarla si è già scritto
abbandonare lei like it doesn't matter a
daniel osmate riccio è finita adesso è
finita per daniele da daniele è finita
california superò look super hook un
gioco di oscar matura è ryan book maker
ma che vuoi poi non possa sbloccare
quando quello gira morto per terra e
spara la gente però figo figo è bello ma
le ragazzine valsa la pena sì perché
carino solo che
dovrebbero non lo so magari migliorare
il fatto che quando quando muori in
teoria dovresti morire quindi ragazzi
spero che vi sia piaciuto a casa
il momento è un mi piace anche vari
social che come descrizione se non
sapessi discrete non ci vediamo lo
fossimo vito bella ragazza
[Musica]